supongamos que se viene una elección y
que queremos determinar si hay una
diferencia significativa entre la
proporción de hombres y la proporción de
mujeres que van a votar por un candidato
dado entonces vamos a ver a la población
vamos a tomar a la población de hombres
ahora con los hombres hay una cierta
proporción de ellos que van a votar por
el candidato vamos a llamar esa
proporción p 1 si va a votar y el resto
de ellos no va a votar o sea 1 - p 1 la
proporción 1 - p 1 no va a votar con las
mujeres pasa algo similar pero voy a
escribir por acá las mujeres en azulito
entonces con las mujeres una vez más hay
una cierta proporción que va a votar por
el candidato que no tiene por qué ser la
misma vamos a ponerle pedos entonces esa
si va a votar por el candidato y el
resto la proporción 1 - p 2 no va a
votar por el candidato no vota y este de
aquí si vota 1 entonces esto de aquí son
distribuciones bernouilli ya que son
distribuciones bernouilli eso va a ser
muy útil verdad nos va a ayudar a
calcular sus medias y sus variantes
vamos con los hombres entonces la media
es lo mismo que la proporción
a ver no le voy a poner que la media
vamos a llamarle 1
uno es igual a 1 y la varianza aquí la
varianza va a ser igual a esta primer no
sabes que déjame usar el mismo tono de
amarillo que estoy usando para hombres y
voy a escribir aquí entonces la media la
media es igual a 1 y ahora la varianza
sigma sub 1 al cuadrado es igual es
igual al producto de estas dos
probabilidades de estas dos proporciones
es p 1 x 1 - p 1 esto ya lo vimos varias
varias veces en los vídeos de
distribución ver no le va a pasar lo
mismo con las mujeres vamos a escribirlo
por aquí la media de vamos a ponerle
mudos es igual a pedos y la varianza
vamos a ponerle sigma 2 al cuadrado es
igual a otra veces bernouilli es el
producto de las dos proporciones es
igual a p 2 x 1 - pedos muy bien ahora
lo que quiero hacer y creo que ya lo
dije al principio del vídeo es ver si
hay una diferencia pues significativa
entre la forma en la que los hombres y
las mujeres votan por este candidato es
decir lo que quiero hacer es preguntarme
si esta diferencia
1 p 2 t significativa entonces hay
alguna diferencia significativa en esta
resta de aquí bueno en este vídeo que
queremos encontrar un intervalo de
confianza del 95% para este parámetro de
aquí es una diferencia de estadísticos
pero sigue siendo un estadístico no
conocemos su valor verdadero verdad pero
lo que sí podemos hacer con métodos
estadísticos es pues sacar un intervalo
del 95% de confianza de dónde va a
quedar ese valor dónde va a quedar p 1 -
p 2 estadísticamente lo normal pues pues
es hacer lo siguiente salimos hacemos
una encuesta de mil hombres y mil
mujeres y vemos los resultados para
evitarnos por el momento eso de salir
supongamos que ya entrevistamos a mil
hombres mil hombres y obtenemos que
seiscientos cuarenta y dos de ellos van
a votar por el candidato esos son unos y
el resto que son creo que 358 pero nada
más le voy a poner que que los demás no
van a votar por el candidato vamos a
hacer lo mismo con las mujeres encuesta
moza mil mujeres
claro lo mejor sería entrevistar a mil
que sepamos que son propensas a votar y
supongamos que obtenemos que 591 de
ellas dicen que votan por el candidato y
el resto dicen que no que no van a votar
por ese candidato muy bien entonces pues
aquí pues mamás así a simple vista
basados en las proporciones parece que
si hay una diferencia verdad pero aún
tenemos que obtener un intervalo de
confianza vamos a ver que realmente
entendemos lo que estamos haciendo lo
que acabamos de hacer es encontrar una
proporción muestral para los hombres
entonces la proporción muestral aquí
pues simplemente es una media muestral
de esta lista variable bernouilli
tenemos 642 unos el resto son ceros son
642 de 1000 entonces la proporción
muestral es la media muestral que es 0.6
42 entonces lo podemos pensar como media
muestral o como una proporción muestral
si hacemos lo mismo con las mujeres la
proporción muestral va a ser igual a 0.5
9 10 puntos 591 o pues podemos verlo
como la media muestral
después todas estas muestras que tomamos
verdad 591 unos y varios ceros
ahora para visualizarlo déjame dibujar
la distribución muestral de las
proporciones muestrales notemos que
tenemos una muestra bien bien grande mil
hombres es mucho más que 30 además
nuestro parámetro quedó entre 0 y 1 como
a la mitad no cerca de 0 y de 1 así que
no es un caso patológico entonces por la
ley de grandes números puesto a ver como
una normal entonces esta distribución
muestral
déjame escribirlo por aquí la
distribución muestral la distribución
muestral de p
ok esta distribución tiene cierta media
por aquí tiene cierta media vamos a
llamarle un de barra
moodle p parra y ésta de aquí ya lo
vimos varias veces va a ser lo mismo que
la media de la población y la media de
la población es la proporción pues la
proporción así verdadera es decir es
igual a 1
excelente entonces la media de la
distribución muestral es igual a 1
vamos con la varianza esto también ya lo
vimos varias veces sin más pues vamos a
ponerle sigma dp1 barra y como es la
varianza hay que ponerle un cuadrado es
igual a por el teorema del límite
central va a ser igual a la varianza de
esta distribución de acá arriba que es p
1 x 1 p 1 dividido entre el tamaño de la
muestra tenemos mil mil hombres que
entrevistamos podemos hacer exactamente
lo mismo para las mujeres entonces una
vez más voy a hacer el dibujo otra vez
tenemos una muestra bien grande es la
distribución muestral la distribución
muestral de
dp le voy a poner pedos barra es decir
esto saca sabes que dejar de poner los
subíndices 1 y 1 para indicar que es
para los hombres y del otro lado hay que
ponerle aquí un 2 para acordarnos que es
de mujeres no hay que olvidarnos de los
subíndices but entonces esta
distribución otra vez se va a ver como
normal y va a tener cierta media que
esta media vamos a llamarle mousse de 2
barras muy natural la anotación entonces
la media de la distribución muestral
para esta proporción muestral para las
mujeres es lo mismo que la media de la
población que ya vimos que es igual a
pedos a la proporción original de
mujeres y entonces la varianza o más
bien y luego la varianza de esta
distribución de esta distribución
muestral va a ser igual a pedos o sea la
varianza de arriba verdad es de 2 x 1 -
pedos entonces es de 2 x 1 - pedos
dividido entre el tamaño de la muestra
muy bien ahora recordamos que nuestro
nuestro objetivo último es encontrar el
intervalo de confianza para la
diferencia entonces pues vamos a pensar
no en las estas en estas distribuciones
muestrales sino en la distribución
muestral de la diferencia de p 1 barra
grande p 1 barra y p 2 barra la
diferencia de estas dos proporciones
muestrales ahora cuando hablamos de
proporciones es exactamente lo mismo que
hacemos para las medias entonces esto es
algo que ya discutimos en los vídeos
pasados vamos a ver eso vamos a ver esa
distribución muestral déjame dibujarla
por acá y bueno solo para dejar las
cosas bien claras este p 1 que es un
0.64 2 no podemos pensar como una
muestra de la distribución de la
proporción muestral lo mismo acá el 0.5
91 lo podemos pensar como una muestra de
la distribución muestral de pedos barra
tomar mil muestras de la población de
arriba y luego sacar su media es lo
mismo que tomar una muestra de la
distribución muestral de la proporción
pero bueno parece trabalenguas vamos a
hacer el dibujo entonces nos quedaría
algo de este estilo verdad nos quedaría
una vez más una normal
pintarla como algo de este estilo otra
vez nos quedaría como campana y tendría
una cierta media por aquí vamos a no
sabes que déjame hacerlo con otro color
a ver amarillo y azul es verde entonces
lo voy a hacer en color verde entonces
ahí está nos queda otra vez como una
normal esto de aquí le voy a llamar la
distribución muestral la distribución
muestral de de este estadístico p 1
barra - p 2 barra ok entonces ésta tiene
cierta media tiene cierta media de p 1
barra - p 2 barra y por cosas que ya
hemos hecho en vídeos pasados sabemos
que esta media de aquí esta media de la
diferencia de las proporciones es
exactamente lo mismo que esta media
menos esta media que es exactamente lo
mismo también que p
1 - p 2 muy bien entonces esto es igual
a p 1 - y con azul
voy a poner p 2 muy bien pasemos a la
varianza la varianza de esta
distribución
hay que ponerle sigma cuadrada de p 1
barra y luego inscribirse
1 - p 2 barra es igual a y otra vez ya
lo hicimos antes es la suma de las
varias de estas dos entonces va a ser
igual a esta expresión de aquí que voy a
copiar y pegar para no volver a escribir
y ésta
y a eso tenemos que sumar esta expresión
de acá a la segunda varianza todavía no
hay que sacar raíz verdad eso es hasta
que hacemos la desviación estándar
entonces es esta varianza de acá otra
vez le voy a dar copiar le voy a dar
pegar y lo pongo por acá estas dos
variantes tenemos que sumar las las voy
a sumar en color verde le voy a poner
aquí más y eso de ahí es la varianza de
la diferencia de las proporciones
muestrales para sacar la desviación
estándar está bien fácil tachamos este 2
es decir sacamos la raíz cuadrada
entonces a la izquierda sacamos la raíz
cuadrada obtenemos la desviación
estándar y a la derecha también sacamos
la raíz cuadrada y ahí está eso de ahí
nos dé phoenix nos daría la desviación
estándar ahora todo esto es muy
conceptual y está muy abstracto pero lo
que queremos hacer es ya meternos de
lleno en el problema de calcular el
intervalo de confianza de 95% para p1 p2
esto es lo mismo que encontrar un
intervalo del 95% de confianza para la
media de la diferencia como me estoy
haciendo el propósito de no hacer los
vídeos muy largos vamos a dejar la
siguiente parte la de encontrar el
intervalo de confianza para el siguiente
vídeo
vemos